you
hi everyone is Gerry let's have a look
at the game from the 1954 World Chess
Championship match this is a round 9
game on the white end Challenger vasily
smyslov
he's paired against Mikhail Botvinnik so
let's dive in and see how this one plays
out we have a French defense sweet Slav
just a few years after this match would
become the seventh world champion we
know our variation advance after c5 and
a three most common nowadays is to knock
the night out we don't have that in this
one instead the pin is maintained now
there's a nice follow up here the move
played in the game you can take a page
out of smooth lobs book b4 this is
looking to do two things one distract
the C pawn from exerting pressure on the
white center and to unpin the knight
so that night b5 is enabled if there's
one square that is weakest in blacks
camp it is d6 and the knight is not long
off from getting there with great effect
now the move played in the game is the
best move in the computer's eyes to
capture on d4 but suppose b4 is captured
it's important to see how this plays out
just for a couple moves Knight b5 would
be the follow-up and d6 is now under
observation
if black picks up a pawn that's no
problem c3 and now Knight d6 is soon to
hurt not only that but other dark
squares come under fire g7 is a
sensitive square and let's not forget
about bishop a3 soon we could have three
the white piece is putting great
pressure on blacks dark squares white is
the preferred side here despite being
down upon more than enough compensation
in this game C takes d4
the night is under fire you could take
the bishop none of the above here Queen
g4 immediately striking where black is
vulnerable g7 is really an awkward you
know this threat on g7 it's an awkward
move to me
computer suggests King f8 g6 as a next
best move none of the above
Bob Manik says you know I'm just not
even going to do that I'm gonna go for
something active play 97 give up the
pawn and look for some activity so we
have a couple captures on the Queen side
that imbalance is now there's an
imbalance now present Bishop for Knight
exchange Queen takes g7 now this is
gonna may sound like a bit of a strange
pop quiz but right now after this last
capture there's one square that sticks
out to me more than any other on the
board what Square is that and why feel
free to pause the video okay this square
right here is a fantastic square now
what makes me say this well I'm looking
at the imbalance right now the Bishop
versus Knight and black is without a
dark square Bishop f6 is a whole f6 is a
dark square f6 also has the control of
upon
what does this mean well it means
ideally there's a dream square for this
Bishop get to f6 and you morph into a
rook you know you are a five-point piece
maybe even more it's a really good
square okay first things first few
choices for black have to react to the
threat white scoops up another pawn in
Knight to d7 as the follow-up
this move struck me as a bit strange at
the moment at first glance
why not go to c6 and throw a punch we're
gonna see why first some defense of e5
and now we see the point flush the Queen
away Knight f8 Queen drops back to d3
Queen takes a 5 so we're at a moment
right now where things have it's a bit
calm right now
those last handful of moves have been
you know punches counter punches or
punches and a reaction to the threat
there's no threat with blacks last move
so this is one of those moments where
you question how to maybe deploy the
pieces what plan to undertake what would
you do here what would maybe be your
next move as white feel free to pause
the video here we go the move played in
the game I really like this move no
development
not gonna hear me say that too often I
like this move because there's no
development yeah this move here h4 is
great
it's a passed pawn and you'd be
surprised to see how fast this pawn can
run it is ideally or the rook is ideally
placed right behind the pawn so it's
every movement has the support of this
piece moreover when you factor in this
unopposed Bishop once it gets to its
dream square f6 this pawn is basically
unstoppable a bishop on f6 does what in
particular control that promotion Square
this pawn is a killer so as the follow
up Bishop d7 Bishop g5 rook c8 Knight d4
this is a brief game where actually only
ten moves out it's a 25 move game yeah
very direct play Knight f5 rook b1 this
is where black falters there's a threat
against b7 this is ignored black is
looking for something more direct
clearly some kind of miscalculation goes
on with blacks next move b6 is a fine
reply instead
rook c4 throwing a punch Knight takes
Knight and now Rick takes b7 so this is
going to be a problem for Team black the
move played in the game rookie 4 how
would you reply in this position White's
under fire White's in check what to do
feel free to pause the video okay here
we go
Queen takes rook anybody come up with
that one yeah after the Queen is
recaptured rook b8 not many choices for
black got a block with the bishop Queen
block would be mate it's coordination on
da and we don't take the bishop in this
position this allows the King to escape
so what do you do
Bishop b5 these bishops are nightmares
and the Queen now has to give herself up
doing something else
this is worst yeah this is yeah this is
this is the worst move because of being
matin - so Queen takes bishop is
necessary Queen takes rook 96
what to do there's a threat on g5 white
is up the exchange now Bishop f6 who
cares about the Jeep on this pawn is
just way too fast that's what happens
rook takes G to h5 Bishop a6 and there's
only one more move in this game h6 game
over the rook is under fire but it does
not matter you can take the rook this
pond will fly no stopping it you're
getting a queen next move with check
it's true in this position there are
other options you could address this
threat against the rook by giving a
check and then playing here but things
can become a little bit tricky what do I
mean well the move III can happen and
you can see a lot of the squares being
watched over by the black pieces that
are right next to the King it's easy to
go wrong
playing as white in this position so
once more h6 is the final move in the
game black resigns but if you give this
check and only then go here how do you
deal with III so this is maybe a good
moment you know what there's only one
move that is winning for white here can
you spot what that is feel free to pause
the video okay the only move that wins
for white is to play Bishop h4 and hold
this point says it's not an easy move to
make this backward move you'd like to
maybe push the pawn or capture here so
pushing the pawn would be no good you'd
end up in a mate in three like this
something else instead of pushing the
pawn if you capture the pawn this is now
going to be a draw after rip takes c2
this pawn is now passed and if you try
to run with this guy now you'd actually
be losing the rook and sacrifice it
suffer the pawn and this pawn is really
fast
so something like this the Knights going
to be able to control this queening
square
needless to say it's very easy to go
wrong white saw it better our best in
this position to ignore this threat and
simply get on with this advance of the
past pun so if it did if this game did
play out after h6 capture h7 how is this
maybe a little bit different after e3
while white is promoting with check and
now you can take here and meet the move
rook takes c2 with rook h7 there's no
longer a fear of the rook being picked
up and well white is ready to now start
having all the fun capturing on f7 and
follow-up checks with the Queen so this
is as far as the way in this one just a
twenty five mover h6 final move in this
one very fast pawn especially when
connected with the rook right behind it
and having a piece around that controls
that promotion square anyhow as usual
feel free to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below hope
you enjoyed it and maybe even took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
you